PROFESSOR ANANT AGARWAL:
Welcome to MITx, MIT's
worldwide online learning
initiative.
We are delighted to have you
join us for 6.002x: Circuits
and Electronics, the inaugural
course of MITx.
OK, welcome to 6.002.
6.002x is the same as Electronic
Circuits course
taken by MIT students as the
first course in an EE or EECS
major at MIT.
This course will help you make
the transition from physics to
electrical engineering.
In this course, you will learn
about a lot of fun things,
including the foundations behind
many cool devices, such
as the smartphone.
The course will be hard and we
want you to stick with us.
It is our hope that you
will have a lot
of fun in this course.
Let me start by introducing
you to our team.
I am Anant Agarwal.
I am the director of MIT's
Computer Science and
Artificial Intelligence
Laboratory or CSAIL.
Like most MIT faculty, I have
a wide range of interests,
including a fascination
around chainsaws.
GERRY SUSSMAN: Hello, I'm Gerry
Sussman, professor of
electrical engineering at MIT.
Been a faculty member
here since 1973.
I build electronics, optics,
computer software, and I
repair watches as a hobby.
PIOTR MITROS: I'm
Piotr Mitros.
I'm a research scientist at MIT,
and I was in charge of
developing the software
infrastructure for MITx.
As a graduate student, I spent a
lot of time traveling around
India, Nigeria, and China,
mostly as part of educational
technology projects.
So I'm very excited to be
helping out with this course.
PROFESSOR ANANT AGARWAL: Whether
we like chainsaws or
watches, we are all passionate
educators.
This course is free.
You will have the opportunity
to earn an MITx pilot
certificate with your grade
at the end of this course.
In this experimental first
course of MITx, the
certificates are also free.
Now, this is a prototype course
and we welcome your
participation and any feedback
you might have to improving
the learning experience.
Let's get started.